I feel like the Luke on your father
moment is something that people just
kind of hear did you know it or did you
watch it you had no idea that was gonna
happen I didn't know that was going to
happen may the force be with me so I can
contain my excitement during this
interview because Kelly Marie Johnson is
here in studio Rose Tico herself how are
you I'm good been such an insane and
journey and I mean Ryan is the best
human ever truly like I I really hope
every actor gets to work with him
because it's just like working with a
friend he's just the best
have you had your your pinch me moment
yet I have them all the time I'm still
having them yeah yeah biggest to date I
guess oh man I probably when I was at
Campbell and someone showed up dressed
like my character and the movie hasn't
even come out yet that was a big thing
yeah and then also just working with all
of these actors that I had looked up to
for so long Laura Dern Benicio del Toro
I can Oscar Isaac you know Leeson I
could the list could go on forever but I
won't bore you it but all those people
having is just it's just insane yeah I
want to go back to when you actually got
the call because we've read a lot of
like you know you were maybe thinking
about quitting acting and you were you
were doing your comedy thing and then
you get the call of all calls and then
you have to just go back to work so what
was that walk us through that moment
uh-huh yeah so I had been auditioning
for this movie for about five months and
it was actually an in person like
meeting with Brian and I was out my day
job and I got a call from agent saying
that Brian wanted to meet with me before
we all went home for Thanksgiving so
this is November 2015 before the force
awakens comes out Wow yes you should
remember that I was auditioning for this
movie and waiting to hear back while all
the marketing for force awakens was
coming out so it was him I tried to get
out of my head but it was everywhere it
was so insane so I go to this meeting
with Ryan and I tell my my co-workers
that I'm going on my lunch break and I
go to this meeting Ryan tells me I
remember that day like it was yesterday
it's just so crazy I remember driving
there and just like shaking cuz I was
just singing to myself either he's gonna
say you have this or he's gonna say nice
try kid like yeah
and so I get there and there's like a
little bit of small talk and then he
says Kelly I want to offer you this role
and I had imagined this moment so many
times and I thought that I would be
ecstatic I thought that I'd be jumping
up and down but I was just shocked and
quiet for maybe a full minute or two I'm
saying are you excited yeah yeah exactly
he goes so do you uh and I was just like
I'm sorry yes but what it's just such a
it was so shocking the whole thing I'm
and then he was like well you can't tell
anyone so what are you gonna do to
celebrate as I said I actually have to
get back to work
so I'm just gonna do that so I just went
back to my day job and answered emails
and answered phone calls like I don't
know I did what was your first memory of
Star Wars and like how did you how did
you get into it I actually didn't grow
up with Star Wars my parents I think
Star Wars is something that normally has
sort of passed down through generations
of families and my parents were I mean
they're refugees from Vietnam so they
were not in this country when Star Wars
came out so as a child I was never
introduced it introduced to it through
my parents um so I actually ended up not
seeing these movies until I got cast Wow
yeah what was the first one you watched
force awakens okay that's the first
movie watch I actually read the last
Jedi before the force awakens came out
is that weird yeah I mean you're
probably yeah so confused oh yeah it's
so crazy what it totally helped me that
like the idea of this franchise that I
already knew was such a big cultural
thing um I was sort of given this
freedom to be honest with that character
and and not have this pressure of making
her like someone else that we had
already seen this universe right but I
mean obviously it's so historical and
you just want to do the whole thing
justice so I'm so did you I mean because
I feel like the Luke on your father
moment is something that people just
kind of hear did you know it or did you
watch it you had no idea that was gonna
happen I didn't know that was going to
happen oh my god is that so weird I knew
that people like always said that was
like a joke but I had no idea what the
context was right and somebody watched I
was like oh my god oh my god oh my god
that's where that comes from
oh my god
because I don't remember like I think I
already knew it I think it was like
something that I had heard yeah yeah
okay like had that like when did you
watch it for the first time 1997 they
rereleased them on the-- right yeah yeah
so my parents never took me to see that
was that because they weren't into it
yeah so weird Rian Johnson is doing
another trilogy and I have not even seen
the last Jedi yet so you know more than
that I do about Ryan in Star Wars why do
you think that he's the perfect person
to take on a new trilogy that's like a
completely blank slate I think that Ryan
isn't afraid to do something that was
different and I think that's really hard
with something that has been established
and something that people love so much I
that movie really feels like it's a
standalone film if that makes any sense
there are great action sequences there
are great characters but every single
character has an arc every character has
some sort of a mental physical or
emotional challenge that they're going
through and it's pretty incredible to
kind of see what he's done with it I
think that he there's not a more perfect
person to make something new in that
universe and I can't wait to see that
new trilogy another thing that he's
introduced us to Borges besides Rose
Tico and then the sexy foxes so here's
the thing I love porks and I tweet about
it all the time do you know when people
are like giving me a little bit of
backlash and they're like I'm gonna
tweet Ashley
recipes involving porks and it's very
fun sir so I want to know where where
you sit with porks I probably should we
be eating them I'm totally Pro pork I
would not eat a pork go they're so cute
so Q can't eat them we're friends
John said he doesn't like them I know I
know we're working on it we talked about
it we're working on it I have to ask you
about our late role princess Carrie
Fisher who is just such a funny person
and who is so smart in this business is
there a piece of advice that she
bestowed on you given that this was you
know your first major major film that
you could carry carry with you yeah I
really think that
I think that Kerry is such an icon not
just as someone who played Princess Leia
but someone who was just groundbreaking
in that she was okay with being honest
brutally so mm-hmm
unapologetically so and I mean there are
definitely pieces of advice that she
gave me but I think the best advice that
she could give anyone is just leading by
example and the idea that if you if
you're kind of messy and if you're kind
of complicated hey guess what we all are
and it's okay to be that in a situation
where maybe maybe millions of people are
listening to what you have to say she
was so brave in that sense and that's
something I didn't truly understand
until I until I think maybe now I'm
still trying to understand it it's scary
to be yourself when people when a lot of
people are watching right and she was so
fearless I truly think that she is gonna
be immortal for it
[Music]
you